hey gq i'm paul meskel and today i'm
going undercover on the internet
this is actually me
[Music]
wikipedia mescal was an under-21 gaelic
footballer for kildare and was a member
of the minute club yes so
i played gaelic football and hurling
from when i was a child
and then the way it works is that you
represent your club which is like your
town
if the county thinks you're able to play
at the county standard they select you
and i got to play minor which is under
18
and under 21 which was a very proud time
in my life
next one as he graduated from the lear
mescal was offered
roles in two high-profile theater
productions angela's ashes and the great
gatsby
due to scheduling he took the great
gatsby starring as the lead at the gate
theatre
yeah so at the end of my final year in
drama school
i got to audition for both of these
there was just something about
getting to play jay gatsby one of the
great literary characters i wasn't able
to turn that down and that was my first
job
as a professional actor i am db
like his normal people character kind of
walder and he attended trinity college
dublin yeah so i went to the lear
academy which is the acting course
attached
to trinity very different to english
that connell studied put um yeah same
college
getting to film in the college where i
studied was a really cool experience i
felt very
full circle and uh it was strange
shooting in places that you used to walk
through to get to your college in the
morning but it's an amazing place to get
to film and i think it's tricky to get
to film there so
it was really really cool quora
[Music]
no seriously it's actually me did you
think the normal people tv series was a
faithful adaptation
of the novel yes i think it's pretty
faithful and i think if anything
we got to expand on what was already
there rather
altering anything posted what is it
about hulu's normal people that are so
connectable
with the young generation i think yes
it's definitely very apt for a young
generation but i think
it's dealing with teams like first love
and
family and class those are different
things that i think
generally go across multiple generations
it's definitely easy to say that it's
connectable to our young generation but
i think it has a bit of a broader scope
than that
twitter
[Music]
should i read normal people or watch the
series first
read the book first watch it second
definitely in that order
the book gives you really strong
understanding of the characters which
then i think really helps when you watch
the series
i wonder how many times in a row you can
binge watch normal people before people
start to worry
asking for a friend i wouldn't recommend
watching
it for the benefit of your mental health
more than once definitely not in a binge
format definitely i would start worrying
if you watched it
three times in a row once is more than
enough to binge it and then just watch
it kind of whenever you feel like your
mental health can deal with it
does paul mescal know he's been
nominated for an emmy
um no it's actually news to me no i am
yes i do
it's great i don't know what else to say
about that
mad how paul maskel cuts about in a pair
of o'neill shorts and gets photographed
like he's a fashion icon but when i
wear an old pair of swimming trunks and
a 10 year old irma half sip for my daily
walk i'm told to wise up
double standards so i need to explain
what an arma half sip
is first for context so a half zip is
like
a sports hoodie and it's um
quite gaa sporting attire and to be
honest i agree they are double standards
and i think
i would praise you if i saw you walking
around in swimming trunks and a 10 year
old arma halfsip
the sex scenes in normal people are so
good because they have an intimacy coach
i urge you to look up what an intimacy
coach is
and how they operate on set because i
can't believe any films get made without
one molly i totally agree
an intimacy coordinator or coach is
somebody who basically specializes in
helping out a production when there's
intimate scenes or sex scenes involved
i obviously haven't shot sex scenes in
any other capacity other than normal
people
and i will hold my hand up and say that
i won't probably be working
on any production where an intimacy
coach or coordinator isn't employed
because
they're vital and should be the gold
standard moving forward if
a hitchcock's directing hitchcockian and
young's philosophies are jungian does
that mean
paul mescal's acting style is a
masculine i'm gonna go with a hard yes
on that and i'm definitely stealing it
so thank you liam kavanagh
this is my tweet saying i'm irish and it
was as a result of
being claimed as british in certain
publications
what does it mean to you being irish i
mean that's a good question
what does it mean to be irish to be
irish is
great it's a double thumbs up for me i
really enjoy it
and yeah very proud to be irish
why is paul mescal so obsessed with gene
kelly why wouldn't you be obsessed with
gene kelly i'm gonna leave that one
there
the real question is did paul mascot
keep connell's chain
no i didn't i gave it to daisy as a
gift oh paul mescal what's your favorite
phineas song oh what's the one
[Music]
uh let's fall in love for the night for
tonight
[Music]
i can't remember the actual title but
it's that one that i'm trying to sing
and i'm not gonna sing here because i'll
just get embarrassed
excuse me mister have you considered
making an ep because i'm here and i want
to give you
my money i haven't considered it i'd
love to give a gq exclusive and say that
i
am considering it but i'm not at the
moment i'm gonna focus on the acting for
a little while
longer i love playing music and
definitely something that i
wouldn't rule out not that i've given up
much thought moving forward
youtube to any irish out there is this a
posh
irish accent i would definitely say that
i don't have a posh
irish accent a good example of a posh
irish accent would be my good friend
fiona shea he is a
classic posh irish accent and he won't
be mad for me saying that
is it just me or does paul sound like
oliver wood
from harry potter is oliver wood the
quidditch coach it is it is the
quidditch coach oliver would i
think has a scottish accent so i'm gonna
go no on that
[Music]
imagine being paul and waking up to the
stones having a video of you dancing
drunk and alone
it's pretty cool
[Music]
that's it thank you for your questions
and i am signing off the internet